my personal ick is watching someone like
chase after a quarter that they dropped
and like rolling away and I'm like I
don't get that I get an Nick from people
that generally say that we are
approaching the 150th episode of
middleground and we need your help to
continue making more episodes join our
middleground patreon and help us make
Middle
Ground I'd rather be popular than be an
A+ student can the agreer step
forward I have had always been like a
straight A kid 4.0 and then I got to
high school and then I realized students
don't care about that like they care
like how you look and I have always had
like self-esteem problems and I'm
diagnosed with general anxiety disorder
and and I'm diagnosed with clinical
depression and it's like a really big
thing to like have people care about me
and I've realized that I'd rather have
10 people like me and have eight people
compliment me every day and I'd rather
hang out with these people instead of
study that's such like a bad like
quality to have and I know it's like not
something anybody should be proud of but
it is a real thing and it is like my
life and it is something that I have
struggled with my whole life up until
like sophomore year of high school and
we came out of quarantine like came back
to school I was like straight A student
like putting a whole bunch of time into
school and I realized like I think for
me what will make me look back on my
life and be like I enjoyed it is not I
was validor in my class and then got
into whatever College I wanted to in
order to study for the for the next four
years then get a masters and PhD I want
to interact with people and I want to
have a good time with people and I think
having fun is in in my view always going
to be more important than great well I
think it's just like like what kind of
like gives you meaning like like I know
like I'm pretty dependent on my friends
like I value like my friendships and the
connections I make over my like
academics but that doesn't mean that I
don't hold my academics to a high value
and I don't try yeah like when I first
came back from quarantine like I wanted
to hang out with my friends I wanted to
see them I wanted to keep that like
connection but like as I got older
honestly like I don't care like I do
want Straight A's can the disagre please
step
forward the mentality that I have grown
up with since I was really young was
school in general like right now Now
isn't supposed to be fun isn't supposed
to be like a time to enjoy yourself it's
you can enjoy yourself but it's supposed
to be a focus on the four years of your
life that'll change the trajectory of
your entire life so yeah I'd rather have
all AIDS cuz I definitely am struggling
with that right now um typical Asian kid
I just want to say like I like my my
parents are both Persian um like
immigrants and so like academics was
kind of like ingrained in me that like
this is like like this is this should be
my priority constantly and it still is
and but it's kind of just this like
underlying like stress like I wish I
could that could just go away but but I
mean it it is really important like I
think that this time in like high school
like not only does it help you develop
like your identity and how you interact
with others and like like how social you
are but I think it also like like really
trying in academics and trying in school
like develops that work ethic that you
need for the future the way I think of
it is like would I really put all my
eggs into the basket of being popular
why should I be so caught up on what
other people think of me when I can
perfect myself when I can try my hardest
to be as smart as I can I think you can
be smart and not have straight A yeah
yeah I agree too having straight A isn't
even about how smart you are it's about
it's about how hardworking you are yeah
but I also feel like as long as you're
trying it's not really that hard but at
the same time I feel like there are kids
that do try their best and they and the
best they can get is like a C+ like yeah
if you're saying that like you just want
to be popular instead of having like
like A's in my opinion that's that's
kind of sad like why are you thinking
that you need to be this person who's
thinking about everyone who wants
everyone to like them who wants to be
liked by everyone when you can focus on
yourself for your future it's a self
it's a self-esteem thing I value other
people's opinions more than my own and
which is so sad like I at the end of the
day I am my own person I should be able
to make decisions for myself but then I
had to come to terms with the fact that
I make decisions for other people and
and I need to stop and it's really hard
to stop doing it's really amazing that
you can recognize yeah I think that that
that's like the first steps towards like
like you know like being comfortable
with that hey you all right yeah just
been in a funk lately hoping some good
thoughts can travel to my head this way
all right not trying to knock your
methods but have you tried talking to
anybody not yet I'm just really
overwhelmed by the thought of trying to
find a therapist yeah I've been there
it's tough you should check out
betterhelp the sponsor of today's video
with better help finding a therapist is
easy regardless of limited options in
your area so you can get the proper help
that you need and it's super convenient
because it's online and remote oh nice I
just filled out a few questions and it
says I'll be matched with a professional
therapist in as little as a few days
whether you're going through a hard time
or you have a clinical mental health
issue you want to address therapy can
give you some great tools to approach
life in a different way so if you're
struggling consider online therapy with
better help to get 10% off your first
month of better help click the link in
the description or visit betterhelp.com
slj media thank you to betterhelp for
supporting this channel now let's get
back to the video I don't know I think
you were on to something here Maddie how
do I get
up
guys there is a strategy to becoming
popular there's not like a code you put
in you know like okay this is how I
become popular but I feel like being
social like gets you can make you like
more popular being in sports makes you
more popular like there are certain
things you can do that can get your like
social status boosted like all
throughout Middle School elementary
school I was just Morgan then I joined
leadership and I started I went up to
the principal I was like hey can I do
morning announcements and I think that
continu to like high school because I
joined leadership again I joined cheer
like I feel like if I didn't do those
things like and like no one would really
like know like I would still might be
known because I'm really social and I
try to talk to people but at the same
time I feel like if I
didn't do those things it would be a lot
harder so yeah I think there's a
difference between being naturally
popular like being naturally funny like
being social and like artificially
popular like you want to be popular you
go out of your way to want to be popular
you know what I mean and you have to
follow strategy for that you can change
the way you look I think you can change
your personality you can be a completely
different person you can conform to like
how other people want you to be you can
be how everyone else is you can follow
like yeah if you're not natur naturally
wanting to be social not naturally
wanting to be like just talking to a lot
of people then I don't see the point of
it like I you can see popularity as
something to like have a strategy
towards but then like you're not really
being who you want to
be I do agree that like there's a
difference between like being just
someone who's like social so like you
just like kind of naturally have that
like popular aspect and that people like
you or people know you but I don't see
it as like a strategy like it's like
reviewing popularity as something that
you can just like like like you just
like reach like oh now I'm popular and
now I'm not yeah it's not like like the
movies how there's like oh Regina George
like the whole school's like oh my gosh
Regina like it's never like that I've
never thought there was a strategy like
I'm just myself like I talk to a lot of
people I'm really social do you think
people who aren't popular can become
popular over time yeah I think all you
have to do like honestly joint football
joint cheer but wouldn't that stry
strategy yeah that's a strategy it is at
my school I think popularity has always
been more about just like are you a
likable person and not like which is a
strategy like if you're like being
likable like being nice to people can be
like seen as a strategy you could be
naturally
likeable also I think like like if
you're going to be a person who's very
outgoing I think that's just who you are
right like I am a person who I think I
would feel very uncomfortable like could
definitely try but I think I just feel
uncomfortable being outgoing with people
we're like talking as if like an
unpopular person is like inherently not
likable or they're not like or they're
not social like like the way of
measuring is like skewed like it's not
fully accurate yeah I think we also are
moving away from popular being like the
popular discussed in like I don't know
Disney Channel or like or like in movies
we're trying to really move away from
that popular doesn't really look like
that anymore no one really like cares
like CH talks to your face or anything
it's a lot different from them when we
were growing up watching movies versus
how we're actually experiencing it it
it's like also interesting that like you
guys label like yourselves like
unpopular whereas like I still think you
guys are extremely likable and like
there's no set definition or like a box
that we can like put people in as like
popular unpopular I don't think that
it's like a a real thing you have to be
goodlook to be
popular
a great social media presence is
important to be
popular I think personally like it
doesn't matter but a lot of people will
kind of be like oh my gosh you're like
Tik Tok famous or you have followers on
Instagram like a lot of people will want
to be in your bubble my friends at the
end of the day like they're more like
popular than me and whenever I post like
something on my Instagram like with all
of us the story gets more way more likes
these are my best friends and at the end
of the day I only love them cuz like who
they are but let's post with each other
more let's take more pictures let's let
everyone know that we're together so
like more people like my story and more
people swipe up and say things M yeah
like if I didn't get 5,000 views I would
take it down if I didn't go viral every
single day I'd literally be on my phone
my best friend like I'm flopping I'm in
my flop era like I'd be so sad without
social media which probably honestly
would be way better for like my mental
health and like just everything but I
feel like without it I would still be
known cuz at the end of the day like I
said I'm still a cheerleader I'm still
in all these programs I still like I'm
very social and without social media
they'd still know oh yeah that's Ming
because at the end of the day it's not
social media it's
me when it comes to like Tik Tok famous
like I don't see that as like popularity
I see that has more like Fame I have
like 1500 Instagram F I'm not like an
influencer though like I don't I don't
have 1500 friends like I post like maybe
like twice a year it's more just like so
people like know what I look like if
they search up my name like I don't put
much thought into like my social media
presence and I don't think that it would
make like that big of an effect versus
like the friends that I actually have
yeah I think there's popular people at
school that can have little to no like
social media presence and then at the
end of the Lou there's unpopular people
who can have thousands of followers like
it all comes down to like how you want
to be presented to everyone versus just
school just outside of school Tik Tok
you know what I mean I feel like the
unpopular person that has more followers
in my opinion I feel like at least like
at their school they'd be like more well
known cuz like oh that kid has like a
ton of followers like oh yeah I know who
that is I know that like at the end of
the day your followers aren't everything
but like like in high school it's like
oh I know who that is like I want to be
friends with them cuz like if I'm
friends with them like I'll get clout
too like stuff like that so that's
interesting you say that cuz I feel like
if I'm like like looking on Instagram
and I see like a like a random kid with
like 4,000 followers like that's all
like Bots like that's that's not like
cool to me or like it's just like what
like having sex makes you more
popular I remember the situation in e8th
grade where there was this girl that
apparently like did it and everyone was
like wow oh my gosh it was like a big
thing I don't really think it's a good
way to become popular but yeah I guess
if your goal was to be talked about
you're being talked about I think it it
does make you more popular especially
since you're young people will talk
about you doing it you'll get more
well-known people will want to have it
with you people will go against it stuff
like that it'll people will just talk
about
it at my school it's actually like you
like a lot of like a lot of people get
like shamed and like picked on like
it's not like really a good like thing
people are just so quick to like
shame people even if it's like barely
anything like exactly like it with like
teenagers like I I think that it's like
a pretty like natural thing but I don't
think that it like correlates to like
popularity in any way like by doing that
like in my experience and like what I
see like I don't think that it makes
someone more popular or less popular
what I think is popular you're known
like you're talked about yeah so I think
when you're having sex and people are
talking about you you're popular for
that reason you know what I mean you
made a good point actually I I agree
with you like I think it's like it'll be
like in Gossip or like people like r a
rumor or like people like question about
it for like relationships stuff like
that but like yeah yes I agree with you
I have roasted someone based on
something they wore
I mean like never seriously like
I like sounds terrible I'm not going to
go to like a random person and be like
why are you wearing that that's but like
like with my like close friends I'll
like make a joke I mean I've talked like
yeah with my friends like I was like oh
my gosh like like what's going on today
like today must be a little rough day
like cuz some people at my school be
looking wild like some girls will come
and they'll have like some some shirts
shirts right here I'm like where's the
dress code like they'll just be looking
wild like with pajamas too I'm just like
all right I feel like girls are like
different because they will roast you to
your face but you won't know like say
like someone was wearing like the most
outrageous outfit like me and my friends
you go up to you and be like wow you
look so good like literally where'd you
get that outfit from and then you'd say
whereever you got it from and we look at
each other' be like okay and then we'd
walk away and then we talk about it in
private like it's just more
fake
so I have this memory from like a while
ago I showed up to my temple like
Halloween event and like a strawberry
shortcake outfit I didn't look the best
but I was like trying to put myself out
there and one of my like closest friends
like she comes up to me and then she
like you know she goes like what the
hell is that what are you wearing it
really really hurt me and ever since
then I kind of just stopped doing that
I've been in Sim similar situations
where you know I've just struggled with
like depression and stuff and when
you're going through that it's so hard
to like even get up in the morning and
like to then be like all right I'm going
to pick out which clothes I'm going to
wear and like this is how I want to look
so I did not dress very well um and
there definitely a lot of times people
would um you know make fun of me whether
it's my friends or like other people so
for me it's just like always been like I
try not to really um say too much about
their appearance or anything like that
just cuz like I'd rather just not do it
at all than risk you know putting
putting someone in in a situation where
they're going to feel feel bad about
themselves I mean I feel like it's like
the like being consider like who you're
around and like who you're doing it to
like like my my friends like we make fun
of each other that's part of like our
interactions and our humor so like I'll
like make like jokes to them like if I
feel like but it's never like with like
malicious like intent yeah I think for
me even when my friends are doing it and
like I know they don't mean it right it
can still affect you it's easy to get in
the mindset of like oh I need to dress a
certain way so my friends don't make fun
of me I feel like if you don't want to
get made fun of or get picked on like
what like clothes wise just wear like
the most basic thing ever like just
pling black plain like just don't don't
try too hard for me I think like if you
dress how you dress just dress how you
dress and I think I think people are
going to make fun of you but like
personally I think people should try to
limit how much they do it um even even
in like friendships or or Social Circles
cuz like at the end of the day you don't
know I'm curious if you've been roasted
before then why are you still doing it
even now as a joke I don't really get
affected by like someone telling me that
like I look stupid like we need to like
stop like caring about so much about
like what what like other people think
that like you're wearing like it's just
not that deep like you know if some
people come to school and they feel like
the most comfortable in like a suit and
like okay go go you I guess go go go do
that being queer is trendy
okay then can all the disagreer please
step forward and tell me what's
problematic with this
prompt it's definitely not a trend I
think it's it's not a trend it's I think
it's just more that like it's now has a
lot more visibility like I feel like a
lot more people know that it's like an
option and they go oh yeah I feel like I
identify with that you know especially
like when like all these like topics are
like so prevalent on like Tik Tok and
social media like it's like inevitable
that we're going to have like
questioning and
like find yourself in middle school I'm
I'm not going to lie I kind of did Think
Like A lot of people just start doing
this so this one girl moved from Florida
and she starts saying like oh I'm by I'm
by I'm bye 30 other girls start saying
they're bye and I was like was like like
like a few months ago I was being a
little homophobic what what happened
like what what's going on here I think
that goes back into being like you're
trying to experiment you're trying to
like what
La I know for tried out of different ofs
fores but just just went back to cuz
honestly it was just a matter of me
trying to figure out what felt right for
me some kids in my school give me the
ick we
just I mean I feel like everyone gets
bothered by something that someone did
is where like I'm probably 10,000
people's X you know what I'm saying like
I like it's it's like a universal thing
everyone's going to get weirded out by
someone or like annoyed that's natural
and mine's like not serious I can't
stand Jorts they drive me insane oh my
God like like I don't sorry like I no
like like maybe it's just cuz I would
never look good in them but like like
it's now it's like trendy and it like
bothers me I have like three coming to
my house like in two days oh my God I
guess one thing I have is like people
who like try and be like super like
trendy almost like this is everything
online I'm going to be that right like
to me that's just a little bit like
extra you know my personal ick is
watching someone like chase after a
quarter that they dropped and like
rolling away and I'm like that's really
embarrassing for you like I think small
things like that like the quarter
running away I don't get that and I'm
like it's people just being human I get
an Nick from people that generally say
that so yeah I guess I don't really I
just like people that comment on small
things like that just people being
people I hate when people
like we'll post a birthday post for
someone and it's like an essay and it's
like you calling me out like why don't
you just text like why like why why do
we all have to read this like paragraph
essay like or when they post their mom
something or like a parent that doesn't
follow them obviously they're like
you've done all this this like I don't I
don't care I read all that it's
important to drink or do drugs to stay
popular I'm kind of like uh like you
know like it's kind of like it's kind of
like a I'm going just sit down and I'm
just explain so I'm going just sit down
I feel like a lot of like kids who do go
out a lot like smoke and drink they also
know a lot of people if they're like at
these parties like you know like they're
having fun good for them I guess yeah if
you want to be in that group that does
that type of stuff sure go ahead but I
don't it's not really prevalent at my
school no one's going to do it no one
really does it
disagre part and doing drugs and smoking
and all that stuff yeah do whatever you
want but I know at my school it has a
very negative effect like I would say
like half of the people in my school um
like smoke weed is sort of the the big
thing my school has also just started to
like be very aware that it's a big issue
so if they see you you're like suspended
for a week people still do it and it's
almost like the people who do it want to
do it more now cuz if you get away with
it it's a lot cooler now cuz it's so
much harder to get away with it that
like what you mean doing it at school or
like oh yeah yeah I mean it's like all
day I like I think like this type of
like these activities are kind of
ingrained in like high school culture
like it's like like it's very normal I'd
say among like teenagers but like you
can really tell when someone like wants
people to know that they do it or like
the people that post about it outwardly
or like do stuff like that like that's
weird you can't be popular and be
disabled
wait I I think it's possible if you're
disabled to like have people who like
you but especially like when it comes to
mental disabilities it is significantly
harder I've known people um who are like
on the autism spectrum or have
developmental disabilities it's just
like it's going to be so much harder for
you to like have to fit in when you said
autism that like really I think that
like that made me remember I had this
really really close friend in elementary
school she was on the Spectrum
and she was bullied like ruthlessly like
it was so so bad and um no one really
wanted to talk to her and it was really
just me and her every time we had recess
so yeah it was definitely just hard for
her to have friends and be liked and let
alone be
popular at my school there's this there
was this girl and she was disabled I
don't know what she had but she was
definitely popular I'd say like everyone
on school knew her she would get invited
to football games she went to prom she
went to homecoming so I wouldn't say you
can't be disabled and be popular like
someone could be popular because they're
a really cool person to hang out with
but I feel like in my experience when
there are people with mental
disabilities who are popular it's not
really because people necessarily are
like I invite them to my house and we
you know hang out it's more so just
everybody sort of has this understanding
of like they're going through something
so we're we're not going to we'll sort
of uplift them so that way they feel
more welcomed I think that's very true
like where like if like somebody who
like stands out for some reason like
whether that's like a disability or they
have like a huge scar or something like
like like they become part of your name
like they they are tied to like who you
are I think the consensus is that yeah
they can be popular but everyone's
really like INF fantasizing them like oh
they're so cute look how they don't they
don't understand those comments that are
like they're backhanded yeah they're
really backhanded are and so yeah
they're popular but definitely not
positively teens are
[Music]
mean I think teens are just naturally
mean honestly especially at this age
when you're going through so many
changes in your your body and your life
I think it just kind of makes sense that
we're mean so judgmental too
Jud that's just just being a human
honestly yeah and it's like you're
learning right now and it's like we have
like a lot of mood swings and like
sometimes we might just come off as rude
to others I like like to think about
like how like little kids like you know
how they're like so brutally honest so
mean like that still like kind of bleeds
in like like as teenagers like it's
we're we're still growing some of us
don't try to be mean like we don't go
out of our way to just be like you know
what I'm just I'm just going to be mean
but like I might like be having a great
day and I might to say one thing in the
wrong tone and it just like ruins
everybody's day like it's just the tone
and like it's just like the way like the
way we say things my parents always are
always saying like you're so argumented
you're so argumentative like I feel like
I never I can never have a proper
conversation with you and it's like I'm
really sorry I didn't mean I don't mean
to I love my parents I never mean to be
mean it's just I think we just don't
have control over that right now yeah if
you guys want to share any Reflections
you have on this or any last thoughts
obviously like like we realize how like
stupid all this is like like popularity
like isn't real like in reality we're
all just like teenagers like trying to
get through High School let's all hug it
out bring it in guys yay oh we look so
aesthetically and cute hold picture
let's W this up Qui period y That's What
It Good in middle school days Middle
School nice to meet you all nice to meet
you too